there's one performance that i have to
ask you about in 2006 at the amas
[Applause]
fans are just going crazy hyper
analyzing the vocals and the body
language on stage can you explain why
you weren't on stage
um with the group from the beginning of
the performance yes i can
melody thornton is finally setting the
record straight on this viral
performance with the pussycat dolls
saying what you don't do to me but i've
seen
[Music]
i had a really bad cold
and we had just gone to istanbul and we
were on a flight
um back to i want i don't know where we
go somewhere in europe
our tour bus was going to then get on to
a ferry i took some
medication because like i was so sick
i could not hear even so i was like cool
can't wait to get on the tour bus i'm
gonna knock out right when i get on
there
and our sound guy who was our tour
manager as well
one of our tour managers he's like okay
here's your passport i
i i'm zoning out i'm in my bunk i'm
zoning out
and i had my passport in my hand and i
just shoved it under my pillow
and went to sleep next day woke up get
off the bus
bus gets on a ferry we go to germany
and we're at the airport in germany and
i don't have my passport
and i could not figure out what i had
done what went wrong i'm like
no so i had to actually
stay in germany i couldn't learn the
choreography
it was the one time through customs that
they were like right we're going to
search you and i was like i really can't
do this right now like
i i'm gonna be performing on the
american musical course
and and um i was met in the car
by hair you know somebody's doing my
hair in the car and then i get my makeup
done and i
have no idea what i'm wearing and i have
no idea what i'm doing
and they said you know just come out on
the end and sing your part
and yeah and that's it i literally
landed
and was on my way to the red carpet
um yeah wow yeah the day that showbiz
that showbiz you make it work yeah oh
yeah absolutely and i was still sick
but you know it is what it is you just
hammer through
right okay so can you put to rest for
anybody who might be watching and
wants to theorize about relationships or
body language in that clip i mean today
what is your relationship with like
everybody in the group today
all stuff that we can't control right i
mean
we all knew that this was both of our
american music awards
um performances were
just it was just like cursed we were
like cursed on the american music awards
and it wasn't always all my fault you
know
at the moment i'm really focused on this
project
i want to give space for myself i want
to give space for the girls
you know if what they want to do is
create a new narrative if that is what
they're doing they're releasing new
music i think
you know i need my space and they need
theirs not in a negative way
just worse yeah just because yes
yeah absolutely yes absolutely i was
just gonna say when is the last time you
guys all spoke have you had a chance to
congratulate one another on
the success of react or the the dropping
of lioness
eyes i think we're all taking space at
the moment and it's okay
and that's okay you know um you have to
do what's best for you
and that's fine there's no bad blood
it's not this thing that's like i
you know it's not that not at all for
any fans out there who are
you know confused because they they love
you and and you might have had the
fantasy of seeing you as a part of the
group
yeah we're involved in those discussions
like you were invited to be a part of
the
the revival and ultimately it was your
decision i definitely talked about it
we kicked around the idea at the end of
it
you know it was it was me
yeah because i had people on my team
saying you know i'd hate for you to miss
you know miss out on on a cash grab or
an opportunity
i don't i'm so sorry i don't want to
live my life
you know on a cash grab and um if that
makes me stupid to some people it makes
me stupid
if it seems really brave and
that's a challenging thing to face and
to also
you know but to move forward then
then okay let's go with that but there
was a lot there were a lot of moving
parts
ultimately i'm not there all the best
um if you adopt an attitude that like
i want the best for everybody i'm
included in that
everybody's included in that every time
something great comes to you
you win every time something great comes
to
other people you win if there was like a
a big anniversary
or a special one-time performance would
you ever consider joining them just for
that one moment
i think if there was ever a star on the
hollywood walk of fame you know
i i would definitely want to be there
you have to be there i was there i was
there
um so yeah that you know that for sure
nicole is still very much positioned as
the lead singer of the group
and as a fellow vocalist i'm just
curious what your thoughts are on that
i don't know exactly what happened
whilst i was there
i know that i was appreciated for the
voice that i had
i don't think that people take into
account that we only released two
albums because it was going really
really well
um maybe there was some marketing plan
that our label had
maybe they had every intention of making
sure that i
sang and then it just didn't pan out
ultimately you know the songs that we
have or the songs that we have
and she sang the lead and and so you
know
i don't know how the girls feel about it
and i hope that communication is a big
thing amongst them and
you know yeah but for you someone who's
a singer you are like i'm here to sing
and if i'm not singing you have to
at some point ask yourself and i'm
asking viewers you know when are you
going to take up space
in this world when are you going to
claim
your purpose in this life and go after
that with
as much you know fire
that you have inside you and put it into
action and
really that's it that's it for me you
know i had to just
i have to just give it everything i've
got
you know in that direction melody's
favorite pcd
song i'm done off their second album
doll domination
[Music]
and this may surprise you it took a
minute for one of the group's biggest
singles to grow on her
i did not like don't ya why
i just i just didn't like i didn't get
it i didn't see
why it was a thing don't you wish your
girlfriend was
hot it felt controversial to me
but you know i'm not putting together a
girl group so i have no idea what works
in that way but i did not like don'tcha
i just didn't like it
well i think you're in the minority
because it is
such a super successful song i want to
say that i love don'tcha now for sure
it grew on me the way that people
responded to it and the way that they
loved it i i
definitely love it i have satellite
radio in my car and i'm telling you the
pussycat dolls are on
at least every single time i get in my
car and drive somewhere for more than 20
minutes
um how often do you encounter your own
work
well how fantastic is that that you know
after 10 years it's still
not dated you know it's aged so well
yeah it's it's fantastic i'm very proud
i'm proud to have been a part
of um a moment in music
that was like you know rihanna and and
um beyonce and you know yeah up there
with the big girl
and now melody has more reasons to be
proud
she just dropped her solo ep lioness
eyes
[Music]
[Applause]
my music is inspired by the late 60s
early 70s
cher and donna summer and edie gourmet
and and jose jose like all of the music
is
exactly what i would say the way that i
would say it loads of passion
and soul and i come from a world that
was very much like this is what you're
gonna sing and this is what you're gonna
say and this is
you know this is who you're gonna be
pink had a hard time coming out of that
fighting her way through that christina
aguilera same thing
you know and it's like they had to
release these projects that were so
left of what you know people knew them
for or
were coming to know them for you know
before you end up even further down this
rabbit hole
i've got to be honest with you this is
who i am i'm curious what your
your top three goals are um as this
solo melody the artist project continues
to thrive
i would love to be in a movie for sure
i'd love to get one of these songs
in a movie as well whether i'm in that
movie or not i'd love to tour this
project i
i would absolutely love to tour this
[Music]
project
you